picking customers that are already
successful is a form of Leverage so for
example if I were to help a company go
from 10 million to 20 million I could
charge a percentage of that now
realistically even getting a company
from zero to one million is harder than
getting a company from 10 to 20. and if
I were to charge the same percentage of
that growth from a company going from
zero to one I would be making what I
make in a day in the company going from
10 to 20. and so choosing to pursue
opportunities where there's already
proven success is one of the fastest
ways of becoming more successful deal
with winners and you will win more